public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président du sénat gérard larcher est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
monsieur je sois et merci d'être avec
nous à ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec les échos radio classique et l'
agence france-presse
plusieurs grandes questions bien sûr au
cours de cette émission au coeur de
l'actualité j'ai envie de dire politico
judiciaire mais on parlera également
programme avec françois fillon est ce
que ce sera l'austérité pour tous jean
francis pécresse vous le demandera
comment votre candidat pourra t-il
rassembler son électorat est repassé
devant emmanuel macron ça c'est une
question que vous pose rahana des scuds
jacques et comment tourner la page des
affaires pour la nécessaire moralisation
politique la vertu républicaine
quelle mesure nous en parlerons avec
michael à metz mais bien sûr d'abord une
toute première question d'actualité
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est la mise en examen de
françois fillon avec 24 heures d'avancé
pour détournement de fonds publics et
recel d'abus de biens sociaux c'était
prévu cerd gérard larcher mais ce que ça
ne fragilise pas un peu plus la
candidature fillon
on savait depuis près de deux semaines
que la mise en examen a été gelé dire au
bout du chemin
elle est acté aujourd'hui c'est
l'aboutissement d'une séquence qui au
fond a empêché le déroulement normal de
la campagne électorale qui est un
dialogue entre des candidats et les
français françois fillon a pris une
décision de s'en remettre au suffrage
universel
la décision du peuple david ayer à
l'espèce oui mais je pense que il là et
je le soutiens dans cette démarche parce
que aujourd'hui à cinq semaines de
l'élection ou un peu plus
et bien la campagne va reprendre ses
droits
et puis les françaises détermineront ils
choisiront et il se choisiront le projet
et le projet françois villon
c'est le seul qui puisse permettre de
redresser le pays alors le projet on va
beaucoup en parler encore de cette
émission mais est ce que vous estimez
que le calendrier judiciaire a été
précipitée c'est le mot qu'a utilisée
françois fillon dans sa déclaration
écrite devant les juges est ce que vous
contestez
le calendrier judiciaire écoutez c'est à
l'autorité de justice de conduire le
calendrier qu'elle entend qu'elle entend
mener pour ma part mais ce que je
souhaite pathos et qu'on rentre dans une
véritable sérénité de la justice
en effet je n'ai entendu personne
personne je parle des autorités
aujourd'hui l'exécutif par exemple
s'émouvoir de la disparition totale du
secret de l'instruction
on retrouve une partie des procès
verbaux dans la presse quotidienne dans
la presse hebdomadaire ayant pas tous
les procès verbaux surtout ceux à charge
je crois que la présomption d'innocence
j'ai le souvenir du débat ici le
rapporteur était michel dreyfus schmidt
où nous parlions
au moment du nouveau code de procédure
pénale du statut spécifique de la mise
en examen qui n'est pas une inculpation
mènera qu'il faut qu'il ya aujourd'hui
un couloir judiciaire il doit en quelque
sorte se dérouler dans la sérénité avec
le parler comme instable et puis un
couloir politique
ce couloir politique c'est celui du
débat que nous devons à ce qu'il faut
fermer le couloir jeu différent dans une
trêve est ce qu'il faudrait une j'avais
jamais eu dans la sélection
j'avais souhaité qu'on pratique la
retenue ça n'existe dans aucun texte
j'assume à bourg lès valence le mois je
suis attaché j'ai confiance dans
l'autorité de justice je l' ai déjà dit
je suis aussi quelqu'un qui propose des
nominations conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
donc je mesure la responsabilité comme
président du sénat qui est la mienne
voilà pourquoi je pense que enfin le
temps de la sérénité les chaleurs c'est
ce que j'appelle d'accord mais il ya des
déclarations fortes à gauche par exemple
certains parlent de parjure concernant
françois fillon puisqu'il avait dit
qu'il ne serait plus candidat s'il était
mis en examen que pensez-vous des bas il
a répondu très clairement si on vend les
français qu'ils jugeront son projet et
lui même et on ne se parjure pas devant
les français c'est les français avec
leur bulletin de vote qui choisiront il
reste trois jours gérard larcher avant
la clôture des parrainages est ce qu'un
plan b alors vraiment ce serait normal
in extremis est selon-vous totalement
inenvisageable
françois fillon est le candidat le
candidat des familles politiques de la
droite et du centre
et d'ailleurs cet après midi j'étais
présent l'accord avec l'ue dit n'en
parlera à 20khz la présence des
présidents de groupe du président de
l'udps et de sensibilité comme le parti
radical et étaient eux autour de
françois fillon avec la famille des
républicains
vous êtes derrière françois fillon oui
depuis très longtemps je lâchais vous
avez eu un moment d'hésitation ces
dernières semaines on peut le dire est
ce que aujourd'hui vous avez vous
peut-être comme les français une autre
image ne cet homme que vous connaissez
mieux que nous après tout c'est chez lui
à un moment où je lui ai posé et des
interrogations
je me suis interrogée au but
poser des interrogations je sais que
certains ont fait dire dans ma bouche
encore récemment un certain nombre de
choses qui me connaissaient bien qu'ils
ne sont pas dans mon vocabulaire
je suis sans réserve aux côtés de
françois fillon
je le soutiens je les fais hier soir pas
de calais dans un village qui s'appelait
cuir devant près de 600 personnes
je continuerai à le faire la semaine
prochaine dans le rhône et je poursuis
actuellement le dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
d'accord ce matin je recevais la cgt par
exemple sur tout après tout c'est dicté
ses découvertes ses révélations à la une
des journaux encore ce matin dans le
parisien est ce que vous n'en voulez
quand même d'une certaine manière
écoutez la vie personnelle de chacun et
sa vie personnelle et son choix je le
respecte profondément
aujourd'hui on est dans un débat
politique un projet à proposer aux
français et je le dis aux français qui
nous écoutent tous qui nous regardent
à cet instant françois fillon est le
seul qui porte un projet qui pour
redresser le pays
alors sans projet on en parle tout de
suite dans la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique qui nous rejoint
bon cela jean français sont soir michel
bonsoir gérard larcher alors soir 100
milliards d'euros d'économie le retour
aux 39 heures la retraite à 65 ans cinq
cent mille postes de fonctionnaires en
moins et la tva +2 points très vite
est-ce que c'est pas l'austérité pour
tous et est ce que vous pensez que les
français ont envie de voter pour ce
projet là les français constatent quoi 6
millions de personnes éloignées de
l'emploi
9 millions de personnes vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et ils entendent un endettement
d'ailleurs qui dépassent l'entendement
pour 2200 milliards de dette
chaque début de mois allez on emprunte
10,15 milliards d'euros pour la fin du
mois et est ce qu'on propose une
espérance françois fillon nous a proposé
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui m'a séduit il ya
un certain nombre d'années dans la
démarche changement de logiciel
retrouvons la confiance la confiance au
travers des entreprises la confiance
aussi dans la maîtrise de la dépense
publique
tant qu'on a pas recréer de la richesse
par les entreprises il serait vain de
continuer l'illusion de vivre très très
au dessus de ses moyens est ce qu'ils
proposent une espérance précisément dans
les campagnes présidentielles il faut
proposer ce que ségolène royal appelé en
2007 à un désir d'avenir on ne voit pas
vraiment dans le projet de françois
fillon voit surtout cette cette potion
amère au fonds d'aidé aux prochaines
années qui nous laisse que nous nous a
proposé françois hollande
le retour vers le plein emploi il ne l'a
pas obtenu parce qu'il n'a pas pris les
moyens en direction des entreprises
le désir d'avenir pour des millions de
françaises et de français pour près de
25% des jeunes qui sont au chômage ou
hors dehors de toute formation c'est
d'abord l'emploi
et ça c'est la première préoccupation de
nos compatriotes ne l'oublions pas le
temps des rêves
pardonnez-moi est comparable au temps de
l'illusion le temps de la réalité du
courage mais ce n'est pas une purge que
de proposer à notre pays d'aller vers le
plein emploi ce ne sera pas demain matin
françois fillon d'ailleurs parle de 7%
c'est pour ça tous que nous avions connu
avec jean louis borloo demande 2007 en
mai 2008
eh oui avant la grande crise financière
qui a quand même ravagé notre économie
comment ferez vous pour supprimer les 35
heures est ce que c'est d'un triple vous
le supprimer dans la loi et à quel
moment à quel seuil se déclencheront les
heures supplémentaires majorées
je crois que pour ceux fillon était
clair mais moi qui poursuit de dialogue
avec les partenaires sociaux
ce matin j'étais avec la cgt et j'ai
proposé la déclinaison qui reste encore
pour partie ajusté à écrire parce que la
démarche de françois fillon c'est
d'abord un homme qui croit au dialogue
social c'est aussi un homme qui propose
un certain nombre de décisions que les
partenaires sociaux ne découvriront pas
en lisant un journal du matin
paraissant principalement de la région
ile-de-france votre confrère le parisien
quel est le projet de texte qui sera
proposé s'il est président de la
république au cours de l'été je souhaite
et la loi travail et actera en amont et
connaissent ce que seront les deux
textes un texte sur la fiscalité on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure un
texte sur le travail fans la durée
légale du travail mais ouverture de
négociations ouverture de négociations
dans les entreprises les entreprises ou
les laurent les branches et dans les
branches alors lorsqu'un à la réalité
des deux sujets des garanties apportées
aux femmes et aux hommes qui sont au
smic et autour du smic
ça c'est le premier des sujets de
seconde et sujet et ce n'est pas des
moindres comment on sécurise comment on
sécurise l'embauchent comment on retire
la peur d'embaucher pour aller vers la
gauche c'est notamment la prévisibilité
et des indemnités prud'homale et 30 elle
renaît
c'est aussi je vais jusqu'au bout
l'ouverture d'une période de dialogue
social entre juillet et l'automne où
nous examinerons la situation de
l'assurance chômage
son rôle dans le retour vers l'emploi
puisque le texte aura supprimé la
question du corps pénibilité comment
reconnaît la pénibilité
ce sera soumis aux dialogues ceci a un
contrat qui sera proposé un contrat
syndicats et aux entreprises entrant et
le dialogue patronaux avec les
partenaires sociaux
ça peut être sous forme d'ordonnancé ou
sous forme d'un texte extrêmement
ramasser qui devrait être proposé au
parlement au cours de l'été mais les sûr
nous achever je reçois jusqu'à lundi
pour le 2e round l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux
le temps des échanges alors les françois
fillon arbitrera définitive est ce que
si françois fillon est élu président de
la république vous ne craignez pas un
troisième tour social assez rude
la démocratie c'est le vote des français
voilà pourquoi avec françois fillon nous
souhaitons qu'on sache tout ah non pas
un aspect du discours du bourget où on
fait l'inversé trois ans plus tard on
s'est tous bien la part ouvert au
dialogue social et ça n'est pas rien
chômage par exemple ton tout justement
sur le passage aux 39 heures dans la
fonction publique mais ce qu'ils restent
une petite ambiguïté sur est ce qu'il y
aura des compensations salariales ou pas
et si oui à quelle hauteur d'abord en
gros est ce que les fonctionnaires
devront travailler 39 heures payées 35
payer 36 payer 37
combien dans la fonction publique impose
le passage à 39 heures c'est une
question d'équité par rapport aux
salariés du privé s'ouvrira dans chaque
fonction publique une négociation avec
la part salariale avec qui sera l'objet
avec l'employeur ou avec avec entre
l'état par exemple et les organisations
syndicales
quelle est la part salariale augmenté
est-ce qu'on modifie l'organisation
est-ce qu'on modifie la conduite des
carrières vous savez bien que ça ait
tenu dans des grilles extrêmement
compliqué c'est l'occasion de ré ouvrir
des négociations dans la fonction
publique qui n'ont pas eu lieu depuis
des années donc on n'en a pas fini ça ça
va être un homme s'est négocié à
progresser les négociations six antennes
à l'âme et 39 heures c'était ça monsieur
macro l'aurait fait
non payées 39 c'est possible je voudrais
que ma connerie l'aurait fait sur le
brouillard est-ce que c'est certes
complexe mais sillage pensum
mais monsieur quelques restes qui vend
les mathieu may cry alors il a d'autres
cas dans ce pays
dans ce pays la part du pib consacrée
aux salaires des fonctions publiques
hospitalière territoriale et d'état est
très supérieure à celle consacrée par
les autres pays et vous le savez bien
c'est vrai que pour et par rapport au
ratio du nombre d'habitants nous avons
près de 60 % d'agents publics de plus
que l'allemagne
est ce que nous nous portons mieux pour
moi est ce que notre salut
fonctionnaires qui sont en poste et
qu'ils ne peuvent rien ils attendent
juste savoir s'ils devront payer s'ils
devront travailler plus sans gagner plus
voilà et le gagnerons pulsions également
d'accord en plus en tant que président
du sénat françois fillon promet une
baisse de dotation aux collectivités
locales de 7 milliards et demi d'euros
sur la législature sur la mandature
après -10 milliards d'euros sur la
mandature de françois hollande est ce
que vous êtes d'accord vous avec cette
austérité pour les collectivités locales
tout dépend dans quelle condition si
nous allégeons les normes ou première
condition si c'est quand même les normes
un coût annuel de 1 milliard 300
millions de normes nouvelles sur les
collectivités territoriales
vous prenez un 3 x sac donc un moratoire
sinon indispensables ont annoncé
toujours par les gouvernements il n'a
jamais volé mais c'est ce que j'allais j
jamais fait l annonce truc mais j'avais
un engagement de françois fillon
il le restera main devant les maires de
france nos questions rapides à leurs
questions sur la clause molière vous
savez c'est cette clause qui permet aux
collectivités territoriales de réserver
des appels d'offres à des entreprises où
on parle le français
ça c'est en ile-de-france une référence
nationale est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette pelouse molaires qui est jugé
comme anti européenne je n'y suis pas
favorable petits personnages les
d'ailleurs dire monsieur martinez ce
matin
ads et un point de désaccord avec
certains de mes amis je suis favorable
par contre à l'engagement très fort que
françois fillon a pris hier sur le
statut des travailleurs détachés
c'est à dire le statut des travailleurs
détachés ne doit pas être
discriminatoire de compétitivité pour
les salariés français
c'est essentiel aussi pour le droit de
ses salariés détachés qui viennent de
l'union européenne
c'est pour moi un engagement à la fois
de compétitivité de non-discrimination
et un engagement européen fort dernière
question sur la question du port du
voile dans les entreprises puisque vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui la cour de justice
européenne a légitimé l'interdiction de
ce voile pour peu que ça ne vise pas une
religion en particulier et ce soit dans
le règlement des entreprises est ce que
vous êtes satisfait de 7,7 cet arrêt est
ce que vous appelez les emplois 16 à re
cindy se mettre dans leur règlement et
il appartiendra la négociation par deux
les bois c'est pour ça que la
négociation et il faut reconnaître que
la loi elle qu'aubry house ouvert la
porte à la négociation d'entreprise
tous ces sujets là doivent être soumis à
la négociation dans l'entreprise
moi qui suis attaché à la laïcité ça
n'empêche pas qu'une entreprise peut
prévoir dans telles ou telles conditions
des conditions et tolèrent au sens du
mot tolérance presque religieux des
signes de la rhel 6 finales mais pas que
le voile d'autres ports pourquoi fait-on
uniquement une fixation sur une religion
merci jean françaix si donc voila vous
assumer à 100 % le tournant libéral a
pas annoncé par françois fillon mais
vous insistez beaucoup on n'y revient
pas sur la négociation il y aura
négociation il avait des sciences
sociales est la dimension sociale et
sociétale deuxième partie de l'épreuve
de vérité avec nadège pull jacques notre
consoeur de la sp pour une question
politique
l'épreuve de vérité avec l'efs
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir monsieur larcher
bonsoir est vous avez vu peut-être dans
le figaro il ya une enquête selon
laquelle 40% des électeurs de droite de
2012 ne vote pas sion alors 40% ces
normes vous allez me parler de la marge
d'erreur mais tout de même 40%
j'ai parlé de rien vous avez raison la
question la question dans ces conditions
comment est ce que vous espérez
rassemblez votre camp rassembler et pas
simplement notre corps rassemblé de
nombreuses françaises et les français
j'ai pas une conception qu'angoua de la
relation ce qui va changer à droite les
hommes les femmes qui se sentent en inde
équation avec la droite et le centre
c'est parce qu'il croit la
responsabilité personnelle
il croit que la liberté permet de créer
mais il pense aussi qu'il existe un
certain nombre de valeurs qui conduisent
la société par laquelle la dimension de
solidarité a du sens
comment rassembler c'est parler de notre
projet or pendant plusieurs semaines
d'ailleurs aucun des candidats n'a plus
parlé projet ne tombe bien on a parlé de
débats bien sûr aujourd'hui faut parler
du projet et les cinq semaines doivent
être consacrés à projet contre projet
vision de la société contre vision de la
société à avoir un dialogue avec les
français avec des sujets aussi
importants je les ai vu que ya
maintenant qui est le sujet de l'emploi
sujet aussi quel est le sens de
l'autorité de l'état
quand on regarde notre dame des landes
quand on voit des 10 et vandalisé par
les propres élèves on se dit qu'il ya la
question de l'autorité de l'état
elle est posée en même temps qu'est
l'europe ont reconstruit à la fin de la
semaine les présidents de parlements
nous allons être à rome pour parler de
la nouvelle union européenne après la
décision britten et comment on refonde
une union européenne est entièrement
projet src mais n'empêche il s'est senti
concerné les jeux qu'on première 20
avait déjà beaucoup parler monsieur
fiant uniquement bond à m'en parler de
son programme
depuis le temps ça fait deux ans qu'ils
le même plus qui nous démarrions g donc
que nous en a souvent parlé m'attendais
j'ai une petite question hier ou
avant-hier je ne sais plus une centaine
de
juppéiste ont décidé de rejoindre
emmanuel macron alors ils tracent
ensemble et rassembler oui mais
n'empêche que les faits sont là quand
vous expliquer que 100 jeunes juppéiste
qui étaient très hautes et jupe et donc
à droite sans manches et macro
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas quelle est
leur motivation ce que je peux leur dire
à ces 100 jeunes c'est que s'ils veulent
demain une société qui donne à la
jeunesse sa place son avenir qui ne la
condamne pas à rester pour 25% d'entre
eux hors formation au chômage c'est pas
le bon choix qu'ils ont fait pour vous
allécher emmanuel macron c'est un
moindre mal
chiche non allégé chez fillon et autour
de son projet c'est la bonne décision
benjamin la question ceux qui veulent
plus aller chez fillon parce qu'il joue
excusez moi et quand même 40 vous dire
une chose c'est sa fille hier soir
j'étais avec xavier bertrand dans le pas
de calais notre première préoccupation
c'était d'empêcher un certain nombre de
nos compatriotes de penser que la
solution le pen c'est celle qui leur
permettaient construit pour ça que je
lui demande s'il serait donc la solution
aujourd'hui s'est massivement d'apporter
son soutien à françois fillon
alors il ya les électeurs de droite qui
ne votent pas cette année effectivement
à 40% à 2 il ya aussi toujours dans le
flou c'est la chronique de jérôme jaffré
il ya aujourd'hui simplement 10% de
l'électorat populaire qui votent fillon
et 10% également des électeurs des
classes moyennes et là il va falloir
aussi augmenté se poursuit
c'est la même question que tu sais la
même question qui tout à l'heure pour
vous imposer un ouvrier employé jeune
premier show électoral marine le pen
nous avons une responsabilité
d'expliquer ce que signifie marine le
pen qui est sûre au plan économique
j'étais hier avec des agriculteurs à la
filière agroalimentaire la sortie de
l'europe c'est moins 40 % de revenus à
des agriculteurs qui aujourd'hui déjà
font en grande souffrance et qui ont
besoin d'une réforme de la politique
agricole commune
sait on le sait ça cent mille emplois
immédiatement dans le domaine économique
en moins
c'est pas moi qui fais l'année c'est
l'ensemble des instituts économiques
c'est aussi la culture du repli sur soi
de la peur de l'autre et moi c'est pas
ma vision de la société et j'ai envie de
dire à ces jeunes à ces ouvriers à ses
employés qui ont le sentiment d'être
abandonnés souvenez-vous dans le rapport
que je faisais au président de la
république en 2015
c'est le gros surge parler de la france
d'un côté c'est cette france des
couleurs préférées
oui c'est celle de guinea périphériques
mais c'est trop tard et elle est par
drogba parce qu'elle a une dent bas
tandis que l'aer est à côté c'est à dire
qu'elle a le sentiment de ne pas être
entendus ne pas être aux côtés de ne pas
être prises en compte et je le voyais
hier au travers de témoignages dans la
ruralité et faire de la ruralité c'est
pas mon priori ce n'est pas simplement
une nostalgie c'est de dire que chacun a
sa place dans la république salue et
remercie nadège dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité avec mes 15 ms donc
de public sénat qui nous rejoint
désormais
[Musique]
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel oncins
dossier larcher bonsoir vous avais dit
en début d'émission la campagne va
reprendre ses droits
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour sortir du
climat des affaires d'abord que nous
parlions de du projet et ce climat me
ramène à ce qui a été ma démarche au
sénat dès ma première présidence je
crois qu'il faut réconcilier les
français avec ce qui est représente
c'est à dire les parlementaires
notamment
vous savez il ya une réalité que vous
connaissez bien
seuls les maires les maires adjoints les
conseillers municipaux la confiance
majoritaire des français c'est pas de la
faute des français c'est notre
responsabilité et là dessus il faut être
exigeant je vous rappelle quand même ce
que nous avons conduits ici je parle de
la période récente
nous l'avons conduit tous les groupes
confondus quand on veut à budget du
sénat plus transparent quand on veut que
les groupes politiques soient tous
organisés en association avec des
comptes certifiés quand on veut encadrer
le régime de l'indemnité représentative
de frais de mandat quand on sait par ans
sur tout ça quand tu pars de l'émoi pas
sous l'effet des événements
nous avons décidé de publier la liste
des collaborateurs
ben justement il faut qu'on soit les
noms au compte de liens familiaux alors
là il ya des mesures qui s'imposent il
existe au sénat au travers de la
transparence et depuis 21 ans je vous
rappelle que quand on a un conjoint ou
un collatéral
on est plafonnée on est plafonnée et ça
existe depuis 1995
monsieur larcher si on reste un petit
peu sur cette campagne nous climat de
cette campagne on a parlé des costumes
du candidat filles ont des enfants du
candidat fillon ce soir on apprend que
le parquet va ouvrir une enquête
préliminaire visant un déplacement des
manuels macron à las vegas las vegas
absolument michel
comment est ce qu'on fait pour faire une
campagne présidentielle je pense que
naturellement et je vais parler d'abord
des parlementaires nous allons entrer
françois fillon a arbitré dans leur du
non cumul des mandats et donc il va
falloir que nous mettions en place la
conclusion d'un certain nombre de
réflexions que nous avons engagé ici
depuis plus de 18 mois
c'est un groupe de travail dirigé par
jean léonce dupont
nous nous sommes penchés sur les pays
aussi qui ont connu ce genre de crise
l'allemagne le royaume-uni par exemple
et nous pensons être en capacité de
proposer un certain nombre
d'orientations pour que la relation
entre les français et leurs
parlementaires feraient une relation
claire et apaiserait delvaux et apaisée
qui concrètement vous avez veut dire par
exemple les emplois familiaux et les
mois les années mitterrand fiscalité les
indemnités la manière dont on gère
l'indemnité représentative de mandat le
régime fiscal des indemnités de fonction
ça conserve
artisan du du scénar est par exemple eh
bien je pense aussi qu'il faut qu'on
renforce dans le cadre d'une réforme
institutionnelle globale tout ce qui
apparaîtra comme conflits d'intérêts
potentiels dans les procédures
législatives
je le dis d'autant plus que c'est ici et
en lien d'ailleurs à l'époque et bernard
accoyer que nous avons mis en place la
première
la première proposition concernant est
allé ce qu'on a appelé les lobbys les
groupes d'intérêts dans nos relations
entre les deux communes d'activité
parlementaire qui est réellement compter
aussi de quelle manière en même temps il
faut respecter la liberté de chaque
parlementaire de voix qui de voir qui il
entend gérard larcher le journal du
dimanche a évoqué un système d'emplois
fictifs au sein du groupe ump qui date
de 2002 et 2014 des primes occultes en
espèces etc
que saviez vous de ce système écoutez on
sait tous depuis 2013 puisque
cette affairé elle a été rendue publique
par un autre par un autre média ya
maintenant un juge d'instruction il
instruit le juge rené cros on va le
laisser instruire et je suis parfois
étonné de lire un certain nombre de
choses qui ne m'apparaissent pas être le
moment il n'y avait rien de neuf dans
cet article
ah non il n'y avait rien 9 qui avec même
quelques erreurs concernant les
associations mais je laisserai aux
associations le soin de le dire il y
avait aussi me semble-t-il une forme d'
amalgame je dois dire que les sons à la
sérénité de la justice le soin de dire y
compris le droit car je rappelle qu'à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de règles des
règles
nous les avons mis en place c'est la
réforme de 2014
ici au sénat pour les groupes et cette
réforme pour les groupes
elle a reçu le soutien de chaque
président de groupe dont le président du
groupe l'est républicain bruno
retailleau
cette mise en cause par l'un des émigrés
ont été mises en cause pendant 12 heures
une phase seront un peu irréel il a par
l'intermédiaire de ses avocats
tout simplement dit la vérité fermez le
bon sur cette affaire c'est ce que vous
supportez rebelles bon j'écoute tout
simplement ce que disent les avocats de
celui qui paraît qu'il avait 10 tab il
paraît que ça a été mal compris tous les
cas je suis très serein mais pas
simplement très serein j'insiste pour
que à chaque fois nous respections ce
qu'est l'autorité justice son
cheminement pour que la vérité puisse
être la conclusion et je le dis il n'y a
de règles posées très clair que depuis
nous les avons souhaité collectivement
c'est vrai j'ai notamment été élu sur la
base d'un projet qui faisait tout
simplement de la mise en place de règles
claires de règles opposables y compris à
l'opinion publique
1 une des propositions majeures
merci gérard c'est d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui
michael bonsoir à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]